MODERATOR: Good afternoon, and
welcome to the Sixth Annual
Space Grand Public Lecture
sponsored by the Massachusetts
Space Grand Consortium.
Our speaker this afternoon has
traveled further than anyone
has, and most likely will ever
travel, to give this lecture.
Jack Schmitt went to
the Moon and back,
and he's going to tell us
a little bit about that.
Now, for the benefit of
those in the audience who
don't have any
gray in your hair,
put yourself back
into the mindset
of the American population
in the late '60s,
and the excitement that
was generated throughout,
not just in the MITs and the
Harvards and the Caltechs
and the Stanfords of the world,
but throughout the community
about the excitement
of preparing
for probably the boldest human
space exploration of all time.
It, of course, reached
its initial excitement
in the footstep that everybody
remembers with Neil Armstrong
and our alumnus Buzz Aldrin.
And it continued on through
a science gathering activity,
which has, in many ways,
never been repeated
in the history of
the space program,
culminating with
the first scientist
to walk on the Moon, our
speaker today, who was also--
and this is somewhat ironic
to look back upon it--
the last man to
walk upon the Moon.
Jack Schmitt, who was a
good friend to many of us
here in Cambridge, began
work as a geologist,
and he had a very promising
career as a geologist.
And when he was selected
by NASA as an astronaut
to train for the Apollo
program, and performed
the way many of us had always
hoped scientists and engineers
in space would
perform in the course
of his exciting
exploration of the Moon.
Beyond that, after return,
and after some important work
with the space agency, he
went on to another challenge,
in many ways just
as great, and that
is in attempting successfully,
to a great extent,
to have his ideas
carried forward
to fruition for the
benefit of all of us
as a member of the United States
Senate, a Senator from his home
state of New Mexico.
And since that
period of time, Jack
has remained active
in a number of areas,
including the space arena where
we continue to bump into him.
I'd be happy to
say, we're usually
on the same side of the
vigorous arguments that ensue.
And what we have asked Senator
Harrison Schmitt to do today
in his talk, A Trip To The
Moon, is talk about not only
what it was like,
but what it can be
like for the next generation.
Senator Schmitt.
[APPLAUSE]
SCHMITT: Well,
thank you very much,
Larry, and I appreciate
the introduction,
and I also appreciate
the opportunity
to speak once more at
MIT on this subject.
I think the last time
was about 20 years ago
and it was to a roomful of
geologists and Earth scientists
from MIT and Harvard.
So I don't think any of
those people are here,
and so I'm probably
not repeating
anything I might
have said and I don't
have to worry about
being consistent.
Larry's exactly right.
What I would like to do is to
take you on a trip to the Moon.
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time getting you back.
Usually, for many
audiences, I do
spend some time
getting everybody back,
but we won't worry
about that today.
Because I [AUDIO OUT] briefly
summarize the first order
understanding of
this small planet
that we gained as a consequence
of the Apollo program.
An extremely important
consequence, and not one that
was anticipated by John F.
Kennedy when he challenged
the nation to go to the Moon
and return safely to Earth,
but one which in the
process of implementation
of that challenge, we realized
a great deal could be done
and, indeed, a
great deal was done.
Also, at various
points in all of this
you'll hear me talk a
little bit about what
I think the future may
hold, not only for the Moon,
but in its now increasingly
symbiotic relationship
with the Earth, and ultimately,
with human settlement
of the solar system in general.
So with that brief
introduction, if we
could have the lights down.
And the first slide,
that's up to me, I guess.
Did it go?
There we go.
And if the speaker
light could come down,
I think the slides would--
You've all seen me, so
you don't need to see me
through this whole thing.
Can I control that, or could
we have the speaker light down?
Maybe we can't do that.
At any rate, we
began these trips
to the Moon in the late
'60s and early 1970s
from the Kennedy Space Center.
And here you see
the Saturn V rocket
to be used by the
Apollo 17 mission,
moving away from its assembly
building, the vehicle assembly
building, towards
the launch pad.
It is still the
largest rocket that
has ever been used to put
human beings in space.
364 feet high.
The basic fully fuel weight
was 6.2 million pounds.
And the five big engines
in the first stage
developed 7.5 million
pounds of thrust.
Now, the Space Shuttle
approaches those numbers,
but does not reach them.
And it was, indeed, exactly
what we needed for this mission.
A truly remarkable
accomplishment
is putting this system
together, and one
which worked with extraordinary
reliability each time
we demanded something of it.
By the way, that vehicle
assembly building is now
fully utilized, unlike
in the Apollo program,
fully utilized by the activities
of the Space Shuttle program.
This is just an alternate
view of the Saturn
V looking from the bottom up.
Those of you who can see in
the lower right-hand corner,
the upper torso of a man.
We'll get a feeling
for scale here.
It's quite a large vehicle.
That D on the fin, left-hand
fin is about five feet high,
I would suspect.
Really awesome, not only from
the bottom, but from the top.
Here, now looking across
the top and the launch
escape rocket that is
attached to our capsule,
that you can see there-- the
cone-shaped capsule at the top
of the rocket, looking back
towards that vehicle assembly
building that I
mentioned earlier.
I generally don't need this, but
that's the building out there.
We were on our way out to
the launch pad at this point,
moving at less than
a mile per hour
on this huge machine
we call the crawler.
By the way, the
crawlers are still
used to transport the space
shuttles out to the launch pad.
Now, we had many different
kinds of training.
Thousands of hours, of course,
in computer-driven simulators
that prepared us for the actual
flight portions of our mission.
But also, we had things
like survival training.
And here you see some
very young and skeptical
looking astronauts
learning about the care,
feeding, preparation of a boa
constrictor at an Air Force
station in Panama.
Ed Mitchell, MIT graduate,
is in that picture, a PhD.
I don't know whether--
Charlie Duke, was he?
AUDIENCE: He was my student.
SCHMITT: Yeah.
Well Charlie's behind the boa.
You might not be
able to tell that,
but I remember that
he was behind the boa.
Now, we also had
science training.
And as a consequence of
the efforts of many people
throughout the country,
including Bill Brace,
here at MIT, and some
Harvard professors
and some Caltech
field geologists,
we finally developed, for
the last three missions,
a comprehensive Earth
science training
program that prepared
pilot astronauts about
as well as one I
think could ever
expect to prepare these, really,
already outstanding observers
to systematically
collect samples,
establish their context
through verbal description
and photography, and to give us
the basis for that first order
understanding of a second
planet that I mentioned earlier.
Here you see Gene Cernan, the
commander of the Apollo 17
mission, and yours truly in
an exercise near Flagstaff,
Arizona, a science exercise.
We actually, each
time we went out
for the most part,
[AUDIO OUT] action profiles,
but working on the
geology, the science,
of real Earth problems.
Why Gene felt, in
this context, it
was necessary to wear
checkered pants I'm not sure.
He was, and I guess
he would still
say is, a Navy test
pilot, and that might
explain the checkered pants.
Gene also was the talker on
the crew, believe it or not.
And here you see
us in an exercise
involving our actual flight
lunar roving vehicle.
We were checking
out all the, what
they call the fit and function
of it in our pressure suits,
and Gene had come up with
something that excited him,
and it obviously
put me to sleep.
But ultimately, on
December 7th, Florida time,
in 1972 we left the Earth with
a spectacular night launch,
I am told.
Having just seen
Discovery launch at night,
I can get some feeling
now for what it was like.
But, of course, I missed that.
And inside the capsule, we were
subjected to, at this point,
not very heavy Gs, because
the initial acceleration
is quite slow, but
extraordinarily heavy
vibration.
In fact, the instrument panel,
switch panel in front of me
as I was lying on my back,
was vibrating so much
that I could not read the dial.
So it was always some
question in my mind,
why did I go through all those
launch abort simulations when
I wasn't going to be
able to read the dials
during that period of time.
Now, on the other
hand, had we actually
had to abort for
some serious problem,
I'm sure my adrenaline would
have focused my eyes as
rapidly as the
panel was vibrating
and everything would have
worked out just fine.
It actually took 14
seconds to reach a point
about like this, go the
length of the rocket.
It took two minutes and 45
seconds to get to a full
acceleration on the first
stage, which was about four g's.
That was the
greatest acceleration
we had during the launch.
But at that point,
we, of course,
had reached the limit of fuel
in the first stage rocket.
We turned it off, staged--
that is, dropped it
off into the Atlantic--
and then reignited the
second stage rocket
in a sequence that went
from four g's to a minus one
and 1/2 g's, as that
whole stack actually
unloaded a little bit, to
a plus one and 1/2 g's,
and all of that happened
in just over a second.
That gets your attention.
The checklists bang
back and forth,
and you know why you're
strapped into your couch,
because otherwise, you
would be banging back
and forth at the same time.
But after we went
through the second stage
and ignited a third stage,
which was actually restartable,
because we will see that
we're going to use it again,
the S-IVB.
We were in orbit
after, as I recall,
a little under 10
minutes, and had a chance
to briefly look at
some spectacular views
of this planet Earth.
Here, the South Atlantic
and its cloud patterns,
the Coast of Africa
and the sand dunes,
and on over the Kalahari
Desert looking down at these
frost-like patterns, actually
turn out to be burn scars--
apparently, fires set
by the local inhabitants
to improve the grazing
for the next season.
Over the Indian Ocean and
the magnificent thunderheads
that one can see
there almost any time,
particularly at the
Intertropical Convergence Zone.
And then to a sunset--
oh, actually, I'm sorry.
These are the atolls of
the Great Barrier Reef,
I believe, near Australia.
And the turquoise
blue, by the way,
shows up extremely distinctly
from way, way out into space.
Quite a remarkable contrast with
the deeper blue of the oceans.
It took 90 minutes to
go around the Earth.
We were traveling at about
18,000 miles an hour.
We'd made two trips
around the Earth
to make sure all the
spacecraft and rocket systems
were ready to go to the
Moon, and indeed they were.
And so at the end
of our second trip,
and after passing through a
sunset, I believe in this case,
we ignited the third
stage rocket, the S-IVB,
began to accelerate over
about a five minute period
to 25,000 miles an hour.
So through a sunrise--
the most spectacular
sunrise I've ever seen--
until we were, indeed,
on our way to the Moon
in nearly perfect trajectory.
At that point, we undocked the
main spacecraft, the command
and service module--
America was its name--
from the S-IVB rocket,
moved away a little bit,
turned around, and then
moved back in in order
to extract the lunar module,
Challenger, which you see here
tucked away and folded it
up in the end of the rocket.
This is the docking
port and tunnel.
We retract that so we all
could go to the Moon together.
Now, those bright spots that
you see around the S-IVB
are pieces of ice.
Actually, ice that had condensed
from the atmosphere in Florida
on the cold fuel and
oxidizer tanks of the S-IVB,
and came off when we shut down
the engine for the last time.
Those are probably what my good
friend and former colleague
John Glenn thought were
fireflies over Australia.
Now he is the Democratic
Senator from the State of Ohio,
and that might explain
that little anomaly.
[LAUGHTER]
The S-IVB sideway,
just so you can
see what it looked
like as it coasted
with us at 25,000 miles
an hour initially,
to an impact on the Moon.
Actually, this became a science
experiment at this point,
because we already had
in place a seismic net
from the previous
missions, and the S-IVB
was a source of
seismic energy, which
we directed in an appropriate
location for science
and seismology on the Moon.
I can't remember now.
I think it impacted after
we had gone behind the Moon,
as you'll see in a few moments.
But once we had the
Challenger in tow,
we were able to look back at
this beautiful planet rapidly
receding from us.
Here, still filling the
window, but eventually not even
doing that, and we were
able to take this very, very
popular picture of
our dear planet Earth,
showing the entire continent
of Africa, most of Antarctica.
A hurricane, our typhoon,
going ashore here on India,
on the subcontinent of India.
Mediterranean there,
and the fronts
that are circling around
Antarctica very nicely shown.
Really, a spectacular picture.
We're all very proud of it.
It is still the most requested
image from the NASA archives,
as you might expect.
The worst use of this
picture that I have ever seen
was in a-- and I'm even going
to mention the name-- a TWA
in-flight magazine where it
wasn't good enough, like this,
and so they moved
Australia over here.
[LAUGHTER]
There is Australia.
This was taken about
a day and a half
after the picture
I just showed you.
We were in now, a lunar
reference trajectory,
as it was called.
And that the Earth was
turning beneath us, once
every 24 hours, and going
through a slow phase
transition, as you see
here, not nearly as full.
And here, looking at
the South Pacific,
you see how brilliantly
Australia, as a desert beacon,
shows up.
And indeed, you could see
the deserts and particularly
Australia very clearly from
the Moon and identify them.
A number of things.
Being an amateur meteorologist,
I filled the transcripts
with all sorts of
descriptions and forecasts
as we went towards the Moon
for three and 1/2 days.
I'm sure I put everybody in
the mission control center
to sleep, but I enjoyed myself.
There wasn't much else to do,
as you travel out towards space,
except make sure you
didn't get into trouble.
This is a typhoon in
the Philippine Sea,
and those spots right there
are thunderheads on each
of the Philippine islands.
Another typhoon was
developing around Guam,
which nobody knew
about, and we were
able to tell the world about.
And particularly the
Air Force was interested
because they had
recovery airplane flying
in that area in
support of our mission.
This speckle point is an
interesting phenomenon,
and actually is a
way in which visually
you can tell what
the sea state is.
It's always brighter,
for example,
near continental shores
because of the increased wave
activity at that point.
If you look carefully,
that's China up there,
and Southeast Asia.
This front has
just cleared Japan.
Japan's not quite so clear
and obvious at this point.
And the Earth
continues to recede.
About three days out, we had
another view of Australia,
but at this point, we
became increasingly aware
of a dark looming shape
blocking out the star field,
as well as the Earth itself
when we headed towards orbit.
And there you see the
mountains of the Moon
across our dear
planet Earth again.
The first sunrise that we had in
the spacecraft behind the Moon
is shown here.
Actually, it's a
sunset on the Moon.
We were in a
retrograde orbit, so
that when we landed on the
other side of the Moon,
in the valley of
Taurus-Littrow, we
would have the sun to our back.
It made just for better
visibility, of course,
than flying into the sun itself.
This illustrates a number
of properties of the Moon
that are of interest.
For one thing, you see
absolutely no evidence
of an atmosphere.
Off there on the
horizon, the vacuum
at the surface of the Moon is
about 10 to the minus 12 Torr.
Basically, no
atmospheric gases at all,
although there is a very
small and measurable amount
of atmosphere.
There's no oxidation
of iron minerals,
so you get none of
the colorful features
that we're used
to here on Earth.
But you do have a
beauty of contrast,
which this picture and others I
think will help to illustrate.
Now, the reason I
show this picture
somewhat out of sequence--
I actually took
this on the way home
just after we left
lunar orbit-- but it's
to give you an indication
of where we were going.
The valley of
Taurus-Littrow, which
you'll see more of in a moment,
cut through a radial valley,
cutting through the ring
of mountains surrounding
this relatively young circular
basin called Serenitatis.
Serenitatis is 500
kilometers in diameter,
somewhat bigger than
Crisium, which you see here,
but not quite as big as
Tranquillitatis, which is
the more irregular basin here.
Apollo 11, Neil Armstrong
and Buzz Aldrin,
landed right there.
That Tranquility Base is in
that vicinity of the Moon.
Our landing, as I say, was
somewhat North of that.
A better view, a close-up view
of the Valley of Taurus-Littrow
is shown here.
It's that dark bay-like
indentation here.
It's about 35 miles long,
about four and 1/2 miles wide.
And those mountains
on either side,
although seemingly
somewhat subdued,
rise to 7,000 feet at
their highest points.
So we landed in this valley,
or a point about right there,
in a valley deeper than the
Grand Canyon of the Colorado.
Truly a remarkable
demonstration, once again,
of the navigational
techniques that
had been developed by the Apollo
program, and in particular,
with the assistance and
innovation and imagination
of the Draper Laboratory, which
then was the MIT Instrument
Lab.
Had they been spun off yet?
I've forgotten when
they were spun off.
Somebody tell me.
AUDIENCE: It was
after [INAUDIBLE]..
SCHMITT: It was after that
when they were spun off.
I am privileged to serve on the
Board of the Draper Lab now.
So I get to come back and
thank them as many times
as I can remember to do it.
This picture was taken
from about 100 miles away.
This one from about 15 miles
away and in a somewhat lower
altitude.
We were only about
10 nautical miles
above the surface at this point.
The landing site is
going to be there.
This spot right here is
the other spacecraft.
Ron Evans, who was the
third man on our crew,
was alone at this point,
since this picture
was taken from the lunar
module, as we prepared
for our last orbit and
descent to the Valley
of Taurus-Littrow.
Ron was about a mile
ahead and a little bit
below us preparing to get
out of the way of our descent
on the next orbit.
This mountain here is
the highest mountain
that borders the valley.
Again, something
over 7,000 feet high.
Looking straight down on
the valley is of interest.
We landed right there, and those
of you who are close enough
will see a dark
shadow or spot there.
That is the shadow
of the lunar module.
Ron actually took this picture
as he passed overhead while we
were working on the surface.
There is a light-colored
spot around this area here
that was caused by the descent
effluence just altering
the optical properties
of the surface.
We've never been able to
detect any impregnation
of the effluence of
the decent engine,
just a modification of
the surface texture.
This feature here, this
plume-like deposit,
is the remains of an
avalanche that came off
the side of the South Massif,
that high mountain I pointed
out earlier.
Very probably in
response to material
thrown over 2,000 kilometers
from the Crater Tycho
in the southern
part of the Moon.
Those of you who look at
the Moon once in a while
will know that name.
It's one of the younger bright
halo craters, bright ray
craters on the Moon.
And it appears as
if one of its rays
comes all the way up here
across Taurus-Littrow,
and we are suspecting
that that avalanche was
triggered by the impact
of that secondary debris.
The ages, as far as we
can tell the age of Tycho,
and the age of this,
about 30 million years,
work out to be
approximately right.
So that's the present
working hypothesis
that we, indeed, had evidence,
or worked on an avalanche
caused by Tycho.
Our traverses, the
first excursion
we worked primarily around
the lunar module deploying
the Apollo Science Package, the
ALSEP, about 300 meters ahead
of the Challenger.
We also sampled around
craters in this area.
The second excursion,
though, we got going early,
we headed all the way out
here about seven kilometers
to that point right there,
and worked our way over
to this dark crater where
we found the orange soil,
and then back to
the lunar module.
And the third
excursion was over here
to visit some big boulders
you'll see in a moment.
Fact is, I think
it's right there.
And then back to there.
So we traveled
about 35 kilometers
in the lunar Rover, which
I'll show you in a moment,
and collected about
250 pounds of samples,
several thousand photographs,
and generally had,
not only a great, enjoyable
time, but a fairly productive
scientific mission as well.
This is the first view I had
out the right-hand window
of the Challenger after landing.
It's a view over a
fairly typical dark, mare
surface of the Moon.
The scattered blocks of
basalt, and the ground up
and pulverized
basalt that makes up
what we call the lunar regolith,
that debris layer, or sometimes
called soil layer,
that covers the Moon.
In this valley it averages
about nine meters thick.
The regolith of the
Moon is the source
of many potential
resources we'll talk about
in a few moments, including
an energy resource,
a light isotope of
helium called Helium 3
that is a nearly ideal,
environmentally, as well
as efficiency, ideal
fuel for nuclear fusion.
The metallic object
there in the foreground
is one of 16 small
restartable rockets
that we used to control the
attitude of the spacecraft
when we were in flight.
The far edge of
the valley there,
say that point right in there,
is probably about four miles
away, something like that.
Now, you have to take my word
for these distances and sizes
and things like that, because
there are no telephone
poles or trees or
houses or anything
that you can use for reference.
And indeed, astronauts,
almost invariably,
underestimated the
distances, like sometimes you
do when you drive in the
Western United States.
When the air is
clear and they have
no clear reference of size,
you will do the same thing.
The Challenger, our home
away from home on the Moon.
Really an excellent camp.
Not only did the descent
stage, the lower half
of the Challenger,
contain everything
that we could need for
our particular mission,
including the lunar Rover
and the Science Packages,
and even our food and film.
The ascent stage was
really a very good camp.
Sleeping in one-sixth gravity
that you have on the Moon
is very comfortable.
We had hammocks that
provided very good rest.
Not enough gravity
to make you want
to toss and turn,
but just enough
to feel like you were
lying on something, rather
than floating.
The food was reasonably good.
Certainly better than I've
had in some of my field camps
that I've worked in
as a field geologist.
No hot water.
We had hot water in the other
spacecraft, the America,
but we did not have hot
water in the lunar module.
That just was not provided
for, and it was not
really necessary for
three days on the Moon.
And maybe most
important for geologists
and maybe some others, there
are no black flies or mosquitoes
to bother you.
[LAUGHTER]
This picture was taken
from about 75 meters away.
Now, you may have
already wondered
did we ever feel homesick.
Well, my answer is no, because
anytime I wanted to see home,
I could just look up over the--
here, the lunar
module, or the nearest
mountain and see the Earth
only 250,000 miles away.
Communications were
excellent, just outstanding.
We never had any communication
problems of any significance
whatsoever.
And we worked almost as if we
were working anywhere else you
could imagine here on Earth.
A well-dressed astronaut
wears what you see here.
The space suit, the backpack,
the emergency oxygen
supply there, and the
man inside weighed,
in this case, about 370
pounds, Earth pounds,
but on the Moon that would
only be about 61 pounds.
Mass didn't change, of
course, but the weight
was quite different.
And so it was really
quite easy to move around.
You had to watch
yourself a little bit.
Your center of
gravity was displaced
about two inches
towards the back because
of the weight of the backpack.
You'll see us leaning forward
in order to compensate for that.
That was very natural to do.
Although, Charlie Duke, when he
was on the Moon on Apollo 16,
decided to demonstrate what it
was like to jump straight up,
and he forgot that his center
of gravity was displaced,
and so he rotated out of
the view of the camera,
and everybody got a pretty
good laugh out of that.
If you ever wonder why
astronauts are whistling
and singing quite a bit while
they're working on the Moon
is because it's so much easier
than training in one gravity.
It really is.
We were basically pressurized
for almost 10 hours
for each excursion, each
of the three excursions.
And the only muscles that
really became fatigued
were your forearm muscles
and the hand muscles.
And that's because the glove was
just purely a pressure glove,
and every time you
wanted to move,
you had to squeeze against
that pressure, 3.5 PSI.
And that would be like squeezing
a tennis ball continuously.
Every time you wanted
to do something,
you had to squeeze a
tennis ball to do it.
That fatigue, these
forearm muscles,
no matter what you had done to
prepare yourself physically,
there was just
nothing you could do.
After about a half hour
or so, you would finally
realize what your steady
state capability was,
and you'd proceed from there.
But the overall loss of
efficiency as a consequence
of that was significant.
And I hope that someday,
maybe some engineer from MIT
will figure out how to
engineer a glove that
more closely duplicates
the normal dexterity
of the human hand.
That's one reason why we
put human beings in space
is to have that hand attached
to a supercomputer called
the brain, and something
that we haven't yet
been able to duplicate
any other way.
The rake that you see there
was just one of the many tools
that we had for collecting
a particular style
of sample, small samples
out of this lunar regolith.
But you also see I'm
not going to the trouble
to grasp that rake, I just
rest it against my hand.
Again, anything you can do to
keep from using your forearm
muscles you would do.
Gene Cernan is testing out
the lunar Rover, in this case.
It weighed about
450 Earth pounds
without us or
anything else on it.
It worked extremely well.
Had four wheel independent
drive, four wheel independent
suspension.
It had front and
rear wheel steering.
You could do either direct or
Ackermann steering with it.
It just worked remarkably well.
Had no problems with the
dust because all the joints
and bearings were
sealed hermetically,
so the dust never was able
to penetrate into them.
Served us extraordinarily
well on all three
of the missions
that it was used on.
Getting on the lunar Rover was
not particularly difficult,
once you learned the tricks.
You stand at the side,
jump up into the vacuum
with a little bit of
leftward translation,
and hope that you came down
on the seat assigned to you.
Commanders tend
to get upset when
you come down in their seat.
It's a little bit like
professors, I guess,
if they find you in
their chair somewhere.
They're paid to get upset, so
we don't worry much about that.
One thing that lunar module
pilots are paid to do,
though, is to repair the
fenders broken by commanders.
On each of our Rover
missions, the commander
succeeded in breaking
a fender off,
and lunar module
pilots very quickly
were instructed on
how to repair it.
Here you see unneeded
photo maps taped together
with, you guessed
it, gray duct tape.
It held the Rover together,
just like it's probably holding
this building together by now.
And it worked very well.
And the reason this was
important-- it wasn't just
a trivial exercise-- is
that in one sixth gravity,
this debris, when
you're driving,
would travel just far
enough up the wheel
to give you a
forward rooster tail,
and you'd be driving
into your own dust
if you did not have something
to break that trajectory.
This picture you
have to look at,
because I like to look at it.
I never tire of it.
It not only brings
back the memories
of the desert-like quality of
the Valley of Tarsus-Littrow
or any place on
the Moon, really,
but it illustrates
just the general nature
of what we were doing.
The lunar Rover off in
the middle distance,
the basalt boulders
around a crater
that's actually on the rim of a
crater 600 meters in diameter,
the largest in the
immediate area.
Probably a crater
formed by those Tycho
secondaries-- we're
just not sure.
Now we're going to stand on
the North side of the valley.
The next few pictures
will be a rough panorama
looking from the East
here towards the South.
This actually looks
along the path
we flew to come into the valley.
This picture over the top
of a very large boulder,
with yours truly
for scale, actually
includes the lunar module.
That spot right there
is the lunar module,
about three and 1/2
miles away with that,
again, lightened
patch of material
at the top of the regolith,
quite visible at this point.
These boulders are made
up of fragments of rock.
They're called breccias.
That's a term that geologists
use for rocks made up
of fragments of other rocks.
And it actually,
almost certainly,
formed as a result of
the huge impact that
created the Serenitatis Basin,
at whose edge we had landed.
And it had rolled down the
mountain from about a kilometer
and a half away, down
about a 26 degree slope
until it hit a break in slope.
Here, we're on about
a 20 degree slope.
And it broke into five pieces.
But you can see here
that the near edge
of the trench, the boulder
track, if you will,
that it made as it
rolled to a stop,
my footprints are
coming down there out
of sight and up the other side.
Those footprints will
stay in recognizable form
for about a million years.
So if you want to
leave your footprints
in the sands of time, this
isn't a bad place to do it.
Certainly far more certain
than going to Washington.
[LAUGHTER] View of
that South Massif,
the highest mountain
in the local area,
that 26 degree slope,
constant slope,
built-in moguls
from small craters
that are formed on the surface.
I think it'd be a great
ski area one of these days.
A 7,000 foot vertical
drop in one swell foop,
that's not too bad.
This is what things
looked like after we
had worked around the
lunar module for a while.
And the Rover is parked
there in its best
position for thermal control.
A lot of the thermal
control was passive.
We tried to keep things as cool
as we possibly could, but not
too cold, because I
guess I should mention
that, say, a surface like
that in direct sunlight
would be probably at
200, 250 degrees C,
whereas in the shadow,
any shadow there,
the surface would
very quickly be
down at about a
minus 150 degrees
C. So tremendous temperature
contrast between the light
and shadow.
Depending, of course, on the
absortivity/emissivity ratio
of the particular surface.
But one reason for
showing this picture
is to illustrate the
nature of that debris
layer, the regolith, in which
our resources are contained.
And it's a lot like
damp beach sand.
It takes a very nice footprint
if you're careful with it.
You can see these
show up very nicely.
But you gradually
will stir it up.
It's slightly cohesive.
When you scuff it, you
get a little bit of dust,
but you also get some clots
that spray out from your boot.
But gradually,
even though it has
a very high, in the
undisturbed area, out
here it has a very
high bearing strength.
No problem at all driving
or walking over it.
As you stir it up,
of course, it starts
to lose that bearing
strength, and that's
an issue for those of you that
some day will design or live
in a lunar base.
You'll have to make
sure that somehow, you
create a surface
on the regolith,
possibly with just aggregate,
that doesn't end up being
a problem for the long term.
Gene took this picture
as we were preparing
to leave after our 75
hour stay, and 22 hours
outside the spacecraft--
both records,
I might presume to say.
Pilots like to keep records.
I'm reminded of that many times.
You see yours truly
preparing to go up
the ladder with a
bag full of samples,
as any good geologist should.
And Gene, however,
was on his way
out to park the Rover so it
could watch our ascent back
into lunar orbit, which
if I'm not mistaken,
it will be the picture
after this one.
This just is a picture
out the right-hand window
again, after we had
completed our adventures,
looking towards the
science station, which
is deployed out in that
area about 300 meters away.
The tracks of the Rover, and
yours truly running back,
or skiing, actually,
back and forth.
Cross-country ski technique
works very well on the Moon.
You can move at 10, maybe
even 15 kilometers an hour
if you work at it.
Stopping's another problem,
but by gliding just
over the surface rather than
on it, you do very well.
The ascent is not
well photographed,
and I apologize for that.
This is taken off of
a television monitor.
Gene tried to persuade me to
go outside and get a really
good picture of liftoff--
[LAUGHTER]
--but I was developing some
political astuteness even
at that point.
And we were on our way-- oops.
Can we turn that one back?
Somebody apparently-- I had to
give the number of that picture
to somebody the other night
and I apparently didn't--
Great.
Thank you.
At this point, I just
want to summarize,
with this picture, some of
the historical significance
of our activities.
I've already mentioned to you
that in the history of science
we developed a first
order understanding
of a small planet, chemically
very much like our own,
with many geological
relationships
to our own planet.
But this was done now by
Apollo for the first time.
And it's a very
significant and detailed
scientific understanding
of that planet,
and has implications
for our understanding
of our own planet.
Particularly, its early history.
And particularly, the origins
of life on this planet.
The astronaut, and in this case,
yours truly with Gene Cernan
reflected in my
visor, symbolizes
for, in the history
of technology,
one of the, if not the
greatest, explosions of know-how
that technology has seen.
And although done in
a spirit, if you will,
of competition with the
former Soviet Union,
nevertheless was done without
a direct threat of war.
And that technology base
continues to benefit us today
in many, many different ways.
The flag of the United
States symbolizes not only
what the country did in
and of itself in response
to the challenge
that was perceived
at the time from the
former Soviet Union,
but also represents, really,
what free men and women can
do when faced with a challenge
that they believe in,
and believe the meeting
of that challenge
is the most important thing
they can do with their lives.
I'm sure you all have heard,
and maybe even use the phrase,
well, if you can go to
the Moon, why can't you,
and then you fill in the blank.
Well, the point is that
you can do whatever
you put into that blank, if--
it's a big if-- if you can
motivate young men and women
like yourselves to believe
that that's the most important
they can do with their
lives at that point in time.
It may turn out
that later on they
have second feelings about
it, but nevertheless,
if the belief is
there at the time,
you can do almost anything.
In fact, I don't know
what is beyond us if we
have those kind of beliefs.
And finally, in the history
of the human species,
symbolized by the Earth
above the flag, and more
appropriately, maybe symbolized
by this view of the Earth
rising from behind the Moon.
We now have both the
technological and psychological
awareness, I think, to move
the human species into space.
There are resources
that can serve
the environment of
the Earth on the Moon,
particularly as we search in
the not too distant future
for that necessary
alternative to fossil fuels.
There are the resources,
additional resources,
on the Moon that can make human
enclaves there self-sufficient.
The same applies to Mars.
And if we have any
kind of long term,
and I mean long term
species survival instinct,
then the enclaves of the human
species on those two planets
are going to be extraordinarily
important to us,
as well as what they do to
enable the Earth, indeed,
to survive itself.
And so Apollo has given
us that new opportunity.
What we do with that, literally,
new evolutionary status
is probably very difficult
to say at this point.
But nevertheless, as a result
of the efforts of Apollo,
including some people
in this room here today,
many people in this
room here today,
we now have options that we
never had before and wouldn't
have without it.
Now, let's digress, as we walk
off the stage here, and digress
a bit to the science by itself.
Before Apollo, and at the end
of the so-called unmanned,
literally, automated
lunar exploration program,
we had a general understanding
of the evolution of the Moon.
That there was a very
old and highly cratered
crust, that it had been modified
by a large circular impact
basins, some more
circular than others.
The Highland basins were filled
with some light-colored smooth
planes we didn't understand, and
by the way, still don't today.
There were almost
basaltic lava flows
in most of the basins on
the near side of the Moon.
There were additional
volcanic deposits
that looked like they had
been pyroclastic, that is,
the kind of fire fountains
that we see today
on the island of Hawaii and
elsewhere around the planet.
And that there was this deep
layer of pulverized debris,
the regolith,
covering all of this
that had developed through
some unknown period of time
since these other
events occurred.
Now, after Apollo, we added
a great deal of detail,
particularly we understand
now the timeframe in which
these things had happened.
The Moon basically began within
the limits of measurement error
at the same time
the Earth began,
about four and 1/2
billion years ago, almost
4.6 billion years ago.
And that is now taken
with the meteorite data
as the age of the
solar system itself.
Early in its history,
right at the beginning,
near the beginning,
there was a magma ocean.
Literally the outer, probably
500 kilometers of the Moon
was molten, or largely molten,
so that it differentiated.
That is, as it crystallized,
light crystals floated
and heavy crystals sank.
And so you ended up with
a crust made up largely
of a light mineral called
anorthositic feldspar,
anorthosite is what
the rock name is used.
And underneath that is
a mantle of the Moon
that is composed largely
of olivine and pyroxene.
And anytime I talk
about this now,
you have to put
in your own minds,
was that happening on the Earth?
The answer is almost
certainly yes.
That these events were
reflected on comparable events
on the Earth, the Earth
being modified by its ability
to withhold a fluid sphere,
whereas the Moon could not.
But nevertheless,
we now have to think
in terms of these events
or comparable events
having occurred on
the Earth as well.
Following the solidification
of the magma ocean,
after maybe 100
million years or less,
the highlands begin
to retain the evidence
of the intense cratering
that was going on.
Indeed, the highland
areas of the Moon
are saturated with craters
at least 80 kilometers
in diameter.
That is, mathematically
saturated
with craters of that size.
An unbelievable
period of violence
in the waning stages of the
formation of the solar system.
And then at some point,
probably beginning
about 4.2 billion years ago,
large basins began to form.
The old large basins
are the irregular ones,
and the newer ones, the
younger ones-- still very old,
3.9 billion years old or so--
are circular.
And that implies in itself that
during that period of time,
the crust was
somehow strengthened.
That is an area of
debate now of how
did that crustal
strengthening occur,
but there has been
isostatic, that is,
compensation of the
gravity anomalies
that would have been associated
with these large basins.
There has not been compensation
of the younger basins.
So something strengthened
the crust at that point,
so those anomalies
could last for three,
almost four billion years.
In this period of
time, the extrusion
of the basaltic lavas in
the Maria reached its peak
and continued for at least a
billion years-- we don't know
exactly how long that occurred.
And then after that things
pretty well stopped.
If you had been around
three billion years ago
and been able to
look at the Moon,
you would have seen
roughly what we see today.
There would have
been bright craters.
They would have been different
than the ones you see today,
but nevertheless, they
would have been there.
And during that
three billion years,
this mature regolith
surface developed,
and began to accumulate solar
wind volatiles, and mostly
hydrogen, quite a bit of helium,
and then, of course, as part
of the helium, the Helium 3.
That is of some interest to us
now from an energy perspective
and an environmental
perspective.
We, of course, also
understand a great deal
about the interior of
the Moon, as a result
of the seismic experiments.
We know roughly it's
layered character,
and from other constraints,
pretty much what
it's composed of today.
So again, we did learn
a tremendous amount
about the Moon and its history
and the history the Earth
as a consequence.
I think I'm going
to leave it there.
If I could have the
lights, and if there
is time for some questions,
I'll be happy to take those.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Do we have time for questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes, we certainly do.
SCHMITT: okay.
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: After completing
[INAUDIBLE] book
on his fellow
astronaut, I was really
struck by his epilogue,
in which he talked
about how the astronauts
reflected on their journeys,
with their own wide
variation in that
and what they've
done since then.
I'm curious if it
does or it does not
invoke certain emotions for you
when you look up in the sky,
and how you've been able
to move on since then
and find the challenges in life.
SCHMITT: Well, the first
question, does it invoke--
when I see it in the sky,
does it evoke emotions?
I must, because I
notice it more than I
remember noticing the Moon.
I mean, it catches my eye,
and that's the best I can say.
If I go around a
building and suddenly I
see the Moon, where
I'm sure prior
to being involved in the
Apollo program I didn't see it,
or didn't notice
it nearly as much.
Or in the Monument
Valley, suddenly it's
there by the side of one of the
mesas, and I just notice it.
But as far as any major change
as a result of actually going
to the Moon, I have
to say I don't think
there was a change in my--
But the maturing
experience of 10 years--
actually, more closer to eight
years-- of direct involvement
in a environment
in which everyone
was totally dedicated to success
of this particular project,
that had a tremendous
influence on, not only my life,
but my perspectives of
what human beings are
capable of doing, as I indicated
earlier, when challenged
and when they believe
in the challenge.
I had an advantage over many
of the other astronauts,
although the vast
majority of them
went on to very
challenging careers,
primarily in business, but
in some other arenas as well.
I also had my science,
and part of my transition
was based on working
on the lunar samples
and trying to
synthesize, which I still
spend some time on today, the
results of the Apollo Science
Program.
So that kept me moving.
At the same time,
some old friends
of Bob Siemens and mine,
George Lowe and Jim Fletcher
asked me if--
and I may have
stimulated the question,
but nevertheless,
they asked me if I
would come to NASA
headquarters to work
on the transfer of
NASA technologies
into energy-related activities.
You see, this all was
occurring about the same time
as the first Arab
oil embargo in 1973.
And it occurred to
all of us that there
might be a great
deal of application
for NASA technologies,
Apollo technologies,
in the energy field.
And indeed, I think
there were, and there
have been, maybe not as much
as I had hoped at the time.
But I worked on that
for a couple years.
And I had always had
in the back of my mind,
from the time I was a
graduate student, really,
at Harvard in the 1960s,
that getting into politics
was something that I probably
would look at very seriously,
and I began to look
at that seriously
while I was in
Washington in '74, '75,
and decided to go back to
New Mexico and my home state
and run for the senate.
There was never
any time in there
to sit back and say, gee,
what am I going to do next?
There was always
something on the horizon.
And I just would
have to say to you
that no matter what goals
you set for yourself,
and I think some
of the astronauts
fell victim to
this, no matter what
goals you set for yourself,
keep them in context
with your whole life.
If it's the only thing you
have as a goal in your life
and you're not thinking
about the future
at all beyond that, then whether
you achieve it or don't achieve
it, you're going to
be at sea for a while.
And I think some
of the astronauts
discovered that was the case
after they'd been to the Moon.
AUDIENCE: Jack, I had a
question about the post Apollo
model of the Moon.
There was an article in
Scientific American this summer
you probably saw called "The
Apollo Legacy," Science Legacy,
and it laid out the
evidence that said,
now we have confidence
that the origin of the Moon
was the result of a major
comet impact on the Earth which
released this large mass
that became the Moon.
And this was followed by a flood
of letters in the preceding
months, and the months that
followed it disputing that.
Do you have any thoughts as to--
SCHMITT: I wish I had
written one of those letters
because I dispute it as well.
You can perform some
fantastic computer
models that make that
a plausible hypothesis.
Unfortunately, I think there
is at least one major bit
of geological evidence that that
model has a very difficult time
explaining, and it has to
do with the orange soil
that I mentioned
briefly earlier.
The orange soil was volcanic
material, pyroclastic-like,
the fire fountains from Hawaii.
There is strong geologic
and experimental evidence
utilizing the orange
soil that that
came from deep within the Moon.
Some components of it came
from below that 500 kilometers
of lunar melting.
And it indicates that
below that depth,
the Moon is largely
undifferentiated.
That is, it's
primordial material.
For example, the lead,
the isotopic composition
that's associated
with that orange soil,
and it comes from
those depths is
what we call parentless lead.
I mean, it's primordial lead.
It doesn't have a great
radioactive component to it,
as you would expect
from other things.
It also has volatile
elements that
are depleted in this
part of the Moon
that was molten at
one time, and they're
concentrated in the
gases that apparently
drove this volcanic eruption.
And it's very difficult--
I won't go into
all the details--
but it's very difficult
for me, and I have not
seen a rational explanation
from the proponents
of the Mars-sized asteroid
theory of how you explain
having a relatively
undifferentiated interior
of the Moon if it
was knocked off
a largely differentiated Earth.
I just don't know
how that works.
So I am a skeptic of that model.
It's a good one.
It stimulated an awful
lot of discussion.
That's what's fun about science
is developing the models
and seeing if they work.
And more often than
not, they don't.
And you go on to the next one.
In this case, I
think that we still
have some explaining to do.
And so I tend to favor, if you
say, okay, what's your idea,
I think that it's probably
a capture phenomenon that
when all the evidence is in that
we'll find that the Moon was
derived in the
vicinity of the Earth,
because of its overall
silicate-dominated composition,
but that it was in a
separate solar orbit,
but one close enough in
Earth-crossing orbit,
and eventually was captured.
And it turns out, that
although in the early days,
the calculations indicated
that was a very, very, very
mathematically, a
very special case,
it now does not look like
it's quite so special.
The work on capture
by a few people
has now indicated that
there are probably
a number of different
ways in which it could be
captured into an Earth orbit.
So that's where I'm leaning
right now is in that direction.
It helps to explain
a lot of things
that I don't think the
Mars-sized asteroid will
explain.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What were your
plans during the mission
if there were a
solar particle event?
SCHMITT: Depending on the level
of the solar particle event,
we would try to put
as much mass as we
could between us and the event.
That was the only plan we had.
We knew that that was
one of the major risks
to the health and safety
of the Apollo crews,
and there was not any
planning beyond that.
Although there was
extensive planning
to how to observe a flare.
Where on the sun and
a flare occurring
would affect the
vicinity of the Earth,
trying to predict how
much time would you have.
And that was worked in
to the contingency plans.
Based on what part of the
mission the event occurred,
you would then move to get
as much mass between you
and that event as possible.
And ultimately meant you'd
get into the command module
as fast as you could, because
that would have the most mass.
And so if we were
on the surface,
we would try to get off the
surface as soon as we possibly
could and rendezvous
with the command module.
AUDIENCE: How much warning
did you feel you had with--
SCHMITT: There is still
some debate over that.
At the time, it was felt
that it was about an hour.
Although some people who
still study that problem
suggest that it may be
only about 30 minutes.
And I can't tell you why there's
that factor of two discrepancy.
They've not been able
to explain it to me,
and I can't explain it to you.
But there is that kind of
a debate going on about it.
But it's not much now.
The only one I know
now, there probably
was a very easy solution to the
lunar surface flare problem,
and that is to use a
linear-shaped charge,
explosive charge,
to create a trench,
drive the lunar Rover over
it, and have some capability
to at least pile dirt, pile
regolith, on top of that Rover.
That would be a very good way
to deal with the mass issue,
and just live off--
by cutting down the rate
at which you're working,
you could live off
your consumables
for a number of hours longer
under that Rover than you would
of if you were working.
Now, you could
augment that solution
by having some additional
consumables on the Rover
that you then could attach
to, with a vacuum transfer,
into your suit.
All of those things
are feasible.
And as a matter of fact, as
we look towards lunar bases,
I personally think
that's probably
the way you'll deal with
that continued hazard
and the risk
associated with it, is
to have those kinds of
systems worked out in advance.
So I don't think
in the long run it
needs to be a major issue for,
actually, permanent activities
on the Moon.
I'll take your question and
then I'll have a closing one.
AUDIENCE: What are your
thoughts about the issues
of manned versus unmanned in
lunar and planetary missions?
I know the American
Astronomical Society--
members of the American
Astronomical Society
are very much in favor
of the unmanned missions,
that they are much
more cost effective.
SCHMITT: Well, I'm in
favor of both of them.
I just was a
principal investigator
on a proposal for
the Discovery Program
to put a lunar Rover, a
new Rover, automated Rover,
on the surface of
the Moon to get
a better three-dimensional
understanding of the lunar
regolith, scientific
understanding of the regolith,
not only for science
in many different ways,
but also to better
understand how
to design future habitats,
machines, and things like that,
that would operate on
and within the regolith.
So I feel very strongly that you
need to find the right balance.
But at some point, you'll always
find me feeling very strongly
that the integration of
robotic or automated technology
and the human
capabilities is ultimately
the way to get the greatest
return on the buck spent.
It's partly my nature.
I hope it's partly a good
logical position to be in.
I just don't see how we
can fully scientifically
or humanistically take advantage
of the opportunities that
are available to us in space
without the combination,
and particularly, without
the presence of human beings
at some point in that pyramid.
The argument will go on.
I have heard people, including
my good friend Carl Sagan,
say that everything
we learned on Apollo
could have been learned
with an automated system.
I'll give him that, but he's
never had to cost that out.
And I just have a
strong gut feeling
as an Earth scientist that to
get that level of understanding
of the history of a
small planet purely
through automated missions
would have cost you
at least as much in then
year dollars as the Apollo
program cost.
And I'm not sure
it would have been
possible with the technologies
that were available then.
Now we have a somewhat
different picture.
What you can gain with some
of the advanced imaging
and analytical mass
spectrometry, particularly
technologies that we
could put on a Rover,
automated Rover on the
Moon, is far and above
what we could have
done 25 years ago.
But still, I think
the argument's
a useful one because it
makes everybody think.
But the other side, shall I
say, if I'm on the man side,
has never really had to
cost out all of these things
that a human being can
do when they're left--
a trained and
experienced human being
can do when they're put into
their own environment in space.
MODERATOR: You asked the closing
question I was going to ask.
So with that, I will thank
Jack Schmitt for a lecture
that we'll remember
perhaps until we
see the next man on the Moon.
Thank you.
SCHMITT: Pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]